hi I'm Shawn Bonner and I am a collector
this is something that I've only
recently come to terms with although the
evidence has been piling up my whole
life I have these huge boxes of things
around my house that through different
cycles and different different times in
my life I've been obsessed with and done
research on and and piled them up and
then gotten bored with them and stuck
them someplace else or sold them off to
buy the next things that I was
interested in and I have a very
complicated relationship with with stuff
that turns out I I'd really hate having
it around I feel cluttered but then as
soon as I clear a space I'm like I need
something to go there and so then I
start researching and finding new stuff
to stick and stick in that spot but it
turns out that that when I look at this
what what what's exciting is not really
the stuff it's the thrill of hunting for
it and so the thrill of the hunt is what
I've realized just this year mostly is
what what really gets gets me excited
and helps me find stuff and there's a
few things that make make that possible
so whatever this object is I have to be
able to know everything about it it
can't be something infinite like wine
that's continuing to grow or whatever I
have to it has to be a finite amount of
information that I can learn the entire
thing from start to finish the stuff
that was made I have to be able to get
it so it can't it can't be stuff that
maybe they made two or three of its out
in the world I have no chance of ever
get it asked me mass-produce enough that
I can actually track it down and I can
complete this collection and then it
also it can't be something like Ferraris
because there's no way I have that kind
of expendable income so the absolute top
tier of whatever this thing is have to
sort of be in my reach plausibly even if
I don't actually go for it and then if
I'm really honest if if all my friends
are into it and I go to their house and
everybody has the same stuff around then
it's boring and and I don't get excited
about it anymore so all those things
come together and then I end up finding
stuff that I have to research this is my
kid and he's in awe of the exciting
world around him
and so in my efforts to constantly blow
his mind I pulled out my record
collection and started playing in my
records mostly because I wanted him to
hear hear different songs and music and
stuff but you know it also the the
physical aspect of playing records
turned out to be pretty cool but I let
him loose on and I said you just pick
stuff go through it and find stuff and
he starts picking stuff not by context
or or by genre but just by record covers
and and he ended up picking out a lot of
a lot of jazz records that I had around
just by covers which isn't isn't really
surprising because that's actually how I
got these records myself too I would go
to a record store and I was I was struck
by these amazing covers and I would say
hey I want to grab these and so he's
playing them I'm looking at him again
and then you know I started I started
doing research and it turns out that
Blue Note jazz records
are an incredibly huge black hole for
collector nerds and I fell into it
earlier this year forget what my next
slide is yeah we just leave that one on
forever okay so for any for any record
that Blue Note released there there's
probably 30 different versions of it and
and they sort of took the let's just
copy a VHS tape a hundred times approach
to it so every version that they
released is worse than the one before it
so people want to get the early versions
not because they want oh I got the first
but because it actually sounds way
better than the stuff they made later
sometimes they would just took a cast of
a record and then use that to make
masters of them but any any Blue Note
record that you pick up there's like 20
different things that can all vary at
any different point to tell you exactly
what year that record was made and then
you can sort of look up to figure out
like what what the sound quality on
that's going to be in so the early stuff
very desirable but even the Holy Grails
of this stuff the very first pressings
from early 60s of some of this stuff you
can still track it down and it's still
sort of it didn't reach so it's not like
you need to you know sell your car or
mortgage or house or anything is if
that's what you are going to do not that
I'm going to do that but if you are but
I also found this weird little black
hole or this little loophole and
and that Blue Note licensed out their
stuff to other countries to make and in
Japan they were incredibly anal about it
and they wouldn't take any of the
existing masters and they made their own
masters off of original tapes and so the
Japanese pressings actually sound way
better than any of the u.s. pressings
past a certain date of course there's
also a bunch of versions for the
Japanese pressings and similar things
happens but that ends up making things
like this incredibly exciting for me and
I can lose a whole afternoon stumbling
across one of these places now hoping to
find one of these little gems and then
that made me try to figure out why is
this so exciting to me and this this
little bit of research why am i all
obsessed about it now and that's how I
came up with these four things and and
it seemed this seems to hit on them and
so if anybody has any old jazz records
around you should give them to me
Thanks